michael shannon reprises his role as zod
i will find him as a baby and kill him
i will kill that baby
[Music]
what up reject nation we got ourselves
some big flash plot details revealed
from the test screenings speed on over
to that like button if you haven't done
so already john
major fan of the flash just read every
comic that's ever existed so yeah we
found a thread that has been posted
everywhere there's one thread and we're
going to react to it in real time see
what's in here spoiler warning i think i
imagine there's spoilers in here this
only stands to reason judge the movie
entirely based off of this and then hold
it against the movie when things are
different whether it be
there's a 100 a tease for reverse flash
when barry's mom is killed a yellow
figure smiles at barry and lunges at him
barry escapes before the yellow figure
can get to him no actor or voice it's
pretty hard to make out the figure uh
because it's just standing in the dark
and you can only see his yellow arm and
red eyes oh
yeah look out at least based off of the
way this first salon sounds is that
there's not gonna be a reverse flash
character in the movie but at least a
setup or tease for him so it's not
exactly directly pulling everything from
flashpoint because reverse flash is
arguably the most personal villain for
barry in a lot of ways especially
because he's gonna kill barry's mom i
guess saving him for a sequel but
setting him up now is is a good idea the
emotional parts are good
oh great good to hear ezra has amazing
chemistry with the woman who plays
barry's mom and i heard people started
crying when barry realized he couldn't
save her thousand times better than the
one in the cw who is playing ezra
miller's mom
the woman he choked that's what that
looks like
look if you stay quiet you could be in
the movie
black flash is not really the villain of
the film it is future flash wearing a
black flash suit which won't confuse
anyone they kind of merged the two
characters it's essentially future flash
just wearing black flash's suit there
are three berries in the film and the
berry we see in the trailers long hair
gets brutally killed by evil berry
that's a reveal okay so black flash is
kind of like a death representation of
the speedsters if i'm not mistaken
future flash was sort of actually a
semi-inspired i believe the character
was savitar
did i remember that sabotage from the
flash series in season three future
flash is like a mournful flash a little
bit corrupted a little bit more
villainous i've only seen the first five
seasons of the flash but i believe that
was season three if i'm not mistaken the
future flash is actually just the second
berry long hair but from the future his
motivation is that when the dcu berry
came to his universe he ruined
everything and destroyed his world damn
he has gotten obsessed into saving his
world and keeps trying to reverse time
from it getting destroyed but it failed
so he decided to go after the person who
caused this our barry interesting there
are plot points that seem sort of pulled
from that exact i mean it's in the comic
so i suppose but i'm like this is also
like the tv series in a lot of ways it
says next feature flash spent 10 years
trying to reverse time and figure out a
way to stop zod from destroying the
world zod zod's instincts do this why
not barry was about to go back in time
but someone future barry tried to kill
him and accidentally knocked him out of
the speed force into an alternate
universe which is michael keaton's world
okay
that's okay so you can just trip and
fall anywhere in the universe so is
barry trying to go back to save his mom
or is he trying to go back
because he knows of the future which is
the snyder verse dark side
thingy
you know what i'm talking about yeah is
he trying to prevent that and then he
goes back or is he going back to try to
save his mom and then he winds up here
is this from the the the climax of jl
you're looking at me trying to save his
mom if that's the prologue of the movie
but michael keaton's batman is still
active and is as unhinged now that
alfred is dead babbitt 89 band returns
are canon the movie addresses at this
batman kills batman forever and batman
and robin have been reckoned away yeah
figures sasha calallas
super girl is car oh
cara zorro she's not the daughter of
superman she is the cousin even though
they cast someone who looks exactly like
the daughter of superman she was the one
to survive krypton's destruction
earthquake instead of cal yeah okay but
was captured by the government upon land
earth entire life locked away in a
military facility like flashpoint yeah
except gender swapped
barry one our barry got stuck in
keenan's world and finds barry two who
also has flash powers and they both get
keaton batman and supergirl to fight a
threat
zod they lose and barry wanted to try to
reverse time to save the universe but it
fails our barry gives up but barry two
dozen that's when future flash future
barry two i wonder what it was like
reading the script because i know in a
visual medium it's really easy to keep
up with but it's like a script format
you're like wait what uh revealing he
tried to repeat time multiple times but
it failed so instead of repeating time
to stop this incident he enters the
speed force to try and kill the person
who causes in the first place barry what
oh wow so all this comes from barry one
hour barry ezra miller the ezra miller
we know and love he's just kind of
debated by others oscar fan favorite
cheer moment ezra miller that's the one
who caused all this it's because of that
cheer worthy vote zod successfully
wait what are we still in act one what
is going on here it seems
how is this layered are we reading this
backwards zod successfully kills kaden's
batman and supergirl supergirl gets her
neck snapped
what the hell it's actually performed
brutal worse than when superman snapped
zodz that's what i want from this movie
how much worse can they get
zod and fowler
my favorite character fiora are alive in
the new timeline
of steel yes i remember her zod killed
cavill superman as a baby killing super
baby
is 100
true that's my favorite thing i've read
so far it works
and we didn't do it for hitler we did it
for superman
that is going to piss some people off so
much
now what a way to prevent superman from
coming into existence by killing the
super baby michael shannon reprises his
role as zod
i will find him as a baby and kill him
i will kill that baby
i want that line exactly future flash
and flash have a massive race because
future flash wants to kill him barry
doesn't want to die that's good uh when
they do that they travel into the
multiverse we see a shitload of
different universes pattinson's batman
universe linda carter wonder woman adam
west batman grant gustin's flash more
ezra's miller pattinson's batman that
will fit it's the right choice what i
mean we're just going to the worlds but
do we see like
cameos or just the worlds i feel like
yeah flash will just run through a frame
and then bruce will turn around really
quick and and then he'll make a joke
about hating it when people disappear
really fast who was that
the answer is justice
hopefully by the end of the movie we'll
see this is looking bleak superman's
existence is left somewhat
ambiguous
schrodinger's what do you mean he's a
dead baby
the best dead baby joke in the dceu any
film and tv show including peacemaker
released between man of steel and chasm
2 are said in the old timeline shasm 2
is set in the old timeline everything
after the flash is set in the new
timeline green lantern zatanna
batgirl i'm trying to understand this so
afterwards a new timeline is going to be
set up right that's what we all figured
would be the main timeline a new one go
this is the correct god what audience we
know what we're doing we know what we're
doing unless you prove otherwise let's
see what like you will change
it again
yeah we'll find a new multiverse reset
button you'll see we'll get it one of
these days iris is only a cameo in this
movie and she only appears at the end
when barry's father is released from
prison
well he gets really yeah good good old
uh wrap up to that story there barry
really made something of himself wb's
plan is to use keaton as a temporary
replacement for to see you batman after
i want to read the crosstalk part after
crisis
which they are leading up to they now
say that they all know that pattinson
will be involved in crisis are they
doing a crisis on infinite earths that's
the implication yeah i mean they were
going to at some point sometimes when
you just want to react on camera
maybe i should have gotten some notes
before doing this nothing of whether he
will join the dcu full-time afterwards
wait a minute why why are they doing a
crisis on infinite earth so soon you're
already hopping a flashback that's the
point of the dc eu that's their theme is
just what we'll do
let's get to the you know what's great
about marvel those culmination movies
what if every movie was just a
culmination movie without the five
movies in between crisis on infinite
earth so you guys might have heard of
secret wars that that's being teased to
possibly come up it's just like
multiverse and madness is coming out and
then you got flashboy coming out and
then so secret wars is like multiversal
wars battles going on that will result
in a specific timeline christ on
infinite earth which was already done on
the crossover which featured ezra miller
by the way
is now happening here
then pattinson i don't feel like just
leave pattinson alone
batman is a good stand-alone franchise
don't let him do it don't haven't seen
say no the answer is justice the answer
is justin oh batfleck here we go
batfleck doesn't die but isn't part of
the new timeline he's just stranded on
it oh cool island in this in the conte
maybe he'll finally get his batman movie
ben affleck lives on it'll make a weird
fracture where now batfleck is the solo
universe not related batman and somehow
battens and gets
folded into the garishness of whatever
the dcu becomes the movie is canon to
the snyder cut hey with iris west
remembering that barry allen saved her
and barry and ben affleck's batman
talking about how barry has time
traveled before to save the day those
references are kept vague enough that
people who didn't watch the snyder cut
won't really be confused i had that
guess that he would have gotten some
inspiration from talking with batman
about how he time traveled that one time
isn't that a greekish so the movie ends
with the creation of a new dce with
keenan's batman and and cod how do you
say your last name
batman is rebooted into a new version
that never killed we're gonna wipe away
his damn sins and his villains are still
alive quick montage of him bonking
people with padded instruments and all
the same scenes i fighters here the
snyder verge becomes a parallel universe
branch timeline bath flight does not die
his last scene sets up his return on
christ on infinite earth's movie that wb
is developing okay just won't let him go
all right let's go to the they got some
big credits post cred john take it away
hey mig credit says that flash will tell
aquaman that he wonders if a superman
exists here too and aquaman looks at him
confused because there ain't a superman
there's not a super nah it then proceeds
to show supergirl smiling at bear and he
smiles back and shows him looking over
what's next to her his face is full of
shock and the movie ends maybe a cave
will not but i don't know his wp going
let's wait to see if they like this or
not we'll bring that reverse back yeah
it's still possible even though we
killed him just now as a baby well no i
mean it sounds like the superman killed
in their universe was a difference it
was different superman and it sounds
like snyder versus especially with
affleck's alive based off what i just
pre-read off this post credits that it
also follows that affleck will can then
continue and i heard something like a
couple days ago about ben affleck going
to see the nightmare of uh
snyder verse world i don't know how to
talk about these things we live in a
society yeah yeah affleck tease post
credits come find us barry affleck
crisis teas oh so it's like a flipper
and it'll be those things and the
answers
is the truth
it's different catholic is now saying
find this berry
well dude i mean
look i have no opinion on this
other than like this sounds wild
sounds
strange and bizarre i think that at
least they're not erasing the snyder
verse from what it sounds like it
actually sounds like they're they're
keeping a separate timeline in case
they're like we need to go back to that
that seems like the smartest aspect of
this whole thing is that they are
embrace i feel like if you're going to
open a multiverse then you should
absolutely have that avenue open and
that is is smart of them to do they
don't have to make a bunch more jl
movies but hey if it's profitable they
can but i'm confused when it says that
zod kills supergirl and keaton's batman
i'm like i thought keaton's batman
wasn't wasn't back
girl bad girl yeah that's a prequel or
uh he gets knocked into the multiverse
at a different point in time too well
guys this news is nuts what do you think
[Laughter]
are you excited i know i am
i was born excited
ezra miller should be held accountable
leave it off on that now how about that
for an indian set up for a casting
change yet i'm still excited for this
movie to see what this turns into and
i'm happy that it's at least getting
well received thanks for being here i'll
catch you guys
[Music]